talk to me about the shift
in the last 20 years
towards really passive forms of
investing
versus active investing and then what
role has the 401k played
so two ways of thinking about it number
one there's nothing wrong with passive
investment vehicles i tell my
my children for for their 401ks do that
don't don't sit there trying to take
stocks
it's it's not something you can do as a
part-time job
right sure you know i i i use a
different reference point which is if
the tile falls off my roof
i could go up on that roof and you know
take a hammer nail knocking
the tile but if i fall off the roof
because i'm not really adept to doing
this
i could break my neck right um so the
risk reward doesn't make sense
pay the guy 100 bucks you know to do it
for you
and similarly i think people work really
really hard for their money during the
day
and they shouldn't be sitting there at
you know eight nine o'clock in the
evening and say okay i'll do some
web searches and i'll you know and i'll
risk my hard-earned money
right so for them you know i think
generally speaking you know
passive products etfs make fair amount
of sense i use them when i go
internationally because i can't do the
work on
you know what's happening in thailand
right so or argentina or something i
just i don't speak the languages i don't
understand the local cultures the
accounting systems make a difference
um so i think it's perfectly reasonable
product to use it's it's an efficient
product
in terms of the cost right okay relative
to mutual funds and things like that
um but on the other hand active
management has its benefits too if you
have good money managers
so so there's still a role for us
there's there's definitely a role factor
the best you know i'm going to share two
fun statistics to put that point
and it may shock people and i do it
almost to shock them
in the fourth quarter last year
37 of the s p 500
beat the market by more than 10
percentage points
okay so if the market was up 10 37 of
the constituents so you're almost
talking close to 200 names 186 or
underneath seven names
right beat the market and they were up
at least 20
wow okay if you look at the first
quarter
performance 32 of the s p 500
constituents so again another 160 names
beat the market by more than 10
percentage points and there's this
obsession almost with five or ten names
that this is
all that's all the market right no no
there's a lot of
good stock making you could have done
even if you forgot about those 5 10
minutes
so there's always been a role for stock
picking the problem is you have to avoid
the losers too
and that's harder um and even if you
look
you you may have a loser that you that
you couldn't help right you
you bought a stock because you thought
the new management that came in was
fabulous and they're really really
great and they're going to turn this
business around they've done it before
you know and you have a lot of faith in
this management team and god forbid
you know the plane that carrying the ceo
crashes into a mountain
yep and your whole story just got
destroyed so that this person's family
but but i'm i'm saying the the notion of
you could have done all your research
and still had some horrible luck
in in terms of your stock picking so i
you know i don't sit there
liberally saying you have to avoid the
losers because sometimes it's out of
your control
right but the the the notion that stock
picking
can make a ton of money is still very
very much the case
it's never gone away it's been one of
the best you know if you go back
decades it's been one of the best ways
to make money is stocking
so i've always felt there's a role for
that even as we've moved towards more
passive vehicles
and for 401ks again it's easier for
people not to have to sit there and
start trying to pick stocks and being
that brilliant
because most of us aren't you know i'm
you know i'm
married 36 years my wife tells me that
pretty regularly i'm not that right
she's generally right but just don't
tell me our clients
um so
but by the same token
you in in one of the recent pieces that
you wrote
you said that we really couldn't hide
behind
the 401k movement as we might have been
able to
in 1982. so what we're really talking
about is
the is household equity exposure so if
you look at the federal reserve board
data
stuff you're familiar with from your
days um
so there's a there's a segment in there
looking at
the household sector which is your
retail investor individual investor but
it tends to skew to wealthier people
because other ones who own the assets
right
um but their exposure to equities as a
percent of their financial assets are
near 50 year highs if not at 50 or
higher right this minute
stocks have not we always get data with
a lack
which means they're pretty fully
invested so over the past year or so
from the bottoms in march of last year
the equity market globally has added 50
trillion dollars of assets it's a
staggering amount
a trillion would be staggering 50
journalists you just
mine can't comprehend that but that's
bumped up
their equity weighting as those stocks
appreciated
and they don't they're not devoid of
investment
participation right they're fully
invested
in 1982 83 i think 84 was the low equity
investing is a percent of finance or
equity holdings a percent of financial
assets are really
really low yeah so that was an
incredibly starting point
as you buy stocks you bid them up by
price right too much demand
none of supply price goes up and that's
what they did and now
if you look at the future based on that
the returns of the next 10 years are
unlikely to be that good based on
when you've had these kind of levels of
investment proportions um
so there's arguments that people have to
use the 401ks today
as a way of building their retirement
because you don't have the fine pension
program anymore
right right but i could have made the
same argument in 1990
90 and i could have made the same
argument between 2000
and we still had some tough years so i
think that that argument
you know people had to do that already
two decades ago
by the way it's hard to even think about
that for a sec but the tech bubble
was more than 20 years ago so you have a
whole new generation of investors
of young people who never have no idea
it ever happened
right because if it didn't happen if
it's not in your memory
it kind of didn't happen